prisons not made to reform you like the
rehabilitation part at the end of
California Department grants and
rehabilitation
there is no rehabilitation there
California is seen traditionally as a
liberal state but not when it comes to
their sentencing laws and their prison
population some prisons were just but
we're so crowded
it was just not feasible to take in any
more people and the previous solution of
building more and more prisons was
essentially not viable anymore
you
I'm here to announce the prison
emergency is over in California today
I've signed this proclamation stating
stating that the troubled situation in
California prisons has been remedy it is
now time to return the control of our
prison system to California the Supreme
Court ruled in 2011 the California's
prisons were so overcrowded they
violated the cruel and unusual
punishment Clause of the Eighth
Amendment almost 25 years after that
ruling California has still failed to
meet its population targets crowding in
California prisons was a key reason why
at that time medical and mental health
care was not being offered at a
constitutional level in states the
state's prisons California hasn't tried
to get ahead of this issue and has
instead just waited for the courts to
grant them another extension to reduce
their prison population over the past
three decades the prison population has
grown by over 750 percent so it's grown
really rapidly over a very short period
of time while many factors drove the
increase in California's prison
population none is perhaps more
significant than the passage of the
three strikes law in 1994 three strikes
requires a sentence double the normal
term upon a second felony offense on a
third felony events the mandatory
sentence is 25 years to life without the
possibility of parole over the past
couple of decades they've passed a
couple of laws that have been seen as
tough on crime when it was cool for
Democrats to pass this type of
legislation it was really pushed forward
by Bill Clinton originally in the 90s
the three strikes laws there was a lot
of that sort of negative campaigning
around being soft on crime in the 90s
and people have recovered from it the
other piece of it I think has to do with
the law enforcement Lobby and the money
that is in politics right now
so it really doesn't matter which party
an elected official is with the
contributions that are coming in from
the law enforcement associations and the
private prison lobby they're tremendous
the California correctional Peace
Officers Association is the state's
powerful prison guard cube and donated
more than $100,000 to the original
three-strikes initiative Justice Kennedy
would later say the three strikes law
sponsor is the correctional officers
union and that is sick but the
investment in three strikes paid
dividends for the Union California's
prisons quickly filled up requiring the
construction of new prisons the hiring
of new staff and diversions of more and
more money into the system California
tried to build its way out of prison
crowding before that built a couple of
dozen prisons in about in less than 20
years and the end result was about 200
percent of design capacity crowding so
it was clear from the past that building
our way out of the problem didn't work
but as the prisons filled up more
quickly than the state could build new
ones some voters began to rethink three
strikes and push to scale it back with a
voter initiative in 2004 the Union spent
half a million dollars to defeat it
these issues poll seventy-five percent
across the population amongst Democrats
it's about eighty percent amongst
Republicans it's about sixty percent so
you really have you know every slice of
the population supporting these sorts of
reforms having a one-party state is not
leading to finding the best solutions
states like Texas and Kansas are taking
the lead on criminal justice reform so
some of the more conservative states are
doing the most and that comes from the
fiscal conservativism perspective two
years after the failed three strikes
reform initiative California's prisons
hit their peak population more than
double capacity and that's when images
like this begins
circulate the overcrowding like created
a whole lot of mess it created a whole
lot of mess for people emotionally
spiritually physically there was no jobs
there was no training there was no
nothing so when people walk out of
prison what did he have they were
styling would get to the reception and
there wouldn't be no beds temper flares
up it gets uncomfortable attitudes um
any vibes if one person gets upset then
it then the person next to him gets
upset you feel that vibe and before you
know it there's just a big old tent
thing and then the rest just goes crazy
California had gotten into the habit of
sending huge numbers of offenders to
prison now with murderers rapists and so
on that's entirely appropriate that's
what the prison system is designed for
but in the past before realignment you
had people committing low-level felonies
receiving sentences sometimes as short
as three months and being sent to prison
realignment is the political term used
to describe moving convicts out of the
state system and into county jails we
immediately saw a population spike prior
to realignment crime in Orange County
had gone down and we had actually closed
our women's jail move those female
inmates into another one of our
facilities we also closed portions of
other jails as well within weeks of
realignment we had to reopen all of
those rather dramatically overnight it
changed the makeup of our jails
realignment is not about passing the doc
it's about ensuring the offender's
who've committed crimes are incarcerated
if necessary and supervised at the most
appropriate level narcotics reports in
the jails went up over 400% crime
reports in the jails went up over 300%
inmate on inmate assaults went up 46%
county jails were designed for short
term housing so when you take a
realigned population who are now former
felons with long sentences and you move
them to the county jail they're being
moved into facilities that were never
meant to hold them for years at a time
if you want to quantify it as a success
in ways that it lowered the state prison
population absolutely it's a success for
the state but I think in the grand
scheme of things if you want to measure
success I don't think we're ready to
measure it the governor I'm here to tell
you I don't believe it's wise or sound
public policy to release any more people
out of our prison other than in
accordance with our existing state law
and that is the reason why we are going
to court asking that the prison cap or
limit be removed in 2010 the California
prison guards Union spent more than two
million dollars supporting the election
of Governor Jerry Brown Governor Brown
of course has shown himself to be very
open to sentencing reform he was the one
who led the effort to pass realignment
but he's also made it very clear that
it's important not to jeopardize the
important changes already made and let
them sink in Jerry Brown has has been
kind of saying that since realignment
the only offenders left in prisons are
the most violent the most dangerous
criminals but that's not really true
actually there's a large number of drug
offenders and nonviolent property
offenders who are still in prison
because of the three strikes law the
second strike aspect of the law so
they've been sentenced as second
strikers ultimately if California wants
to get serious about prison reform
one-step it could take would be to
eliminate three strikes or at least only
have it applied to violent or serious
offenders drug policy is the major
driver in mass incarceration both in
California and nationwide incarceration
for other offenses is fairly steady over
time but if you look at incarceration
rates dating back to the 1980s to now
you'll see just this huge increase a
400% increase and it's really about it's
about drug offenses here in Orange
County when you look at things of that
nature
the community demands that we enforce
those things so I don't necessarily see
decriminalizing things are veering away
from enforcing laws that apply to
realigned inmates as a solution here in
Orange County it's not really my place
to say whether or not a nonviolent drug
offender belongs in prison for X M at a
time that decision is made by elected
officials and
or by the the voters of California all I
can say is that if there were
significant changes made the sentencing
laws in California the likely result
would be a reduction in the prison
population